in 1895 a physicist named Wilhelm
roentgen was doing experiments with a
cathode tube a glass container in which
a beam of electrons lights up a
fluorescent window he had wrapped
cardboard around the tube to keep the
fluorescent light from escaping when
something peculiar happened another
screen outside the tube was glowing
in other words invisible rays had passed
through the cardboard Wilhelm had no
idea what those rays were so he called
them x-rays and his discovery eventually
won him a Nobel Prize here's what we now
know was happening when high-energy
electrons in the cathode tube hit a
metal component they either got slowed
down and released extra energy or kicked
off electrons from the atoms they hit
which triggered a reshuffling that again
released energy in both cases the energy
was emitted in the form of x-rays which
is a type of electromagnetic radiation
with higher energy than visible light
and lower energy than gamma rays x-rays
are powerful enough to fly through many
kinds of matter as if they are
semi-transparent and they're
particularly useful for medical
applications because they can make
images of organs like bones without
harming them although they do have a
small chance of causing mutations in
reproductive organs and tissues like the
thyroid which is why lead aprons are
often used to block them when x-rays
interact with matter they collide with
electrons
sometimes the x-ray transfers all of its
energy to the matter and gets absorbed
other times it only transfers some of
its energy and the rest is scattered the
frequency of these outcomes depends on
how many electrons the x-rays are likely
to hit collisions are more likely if a
material is dense or if it's made of
elements with higher atomic numbers
which means more electrons bones are
dense and full of calcium which has a
relatively high atomic number so they
absorb x-rays pretty well
soft-tissue on the other hand isn't as
dense and contains mostly lower atomic
number elements like carbon hydrogen and
oxygen
so more of the X rays penetrate tissues
like lungs and muscles darkening the
film these 2d pictures are only useful
up to a point though when X rays travel
through the body they can interact with
many atoms along the path what is
recorded on the film reflects the sum of
all those interactions it's like trying
to print a hundred pages of a novel on a
single sheet of paper to see what's
really going on
you would have to take x-ray views from
many angles around the body and use them
to construct an internal image and
that's something doctors do all the time
in a procedure called a CT computed
tomography scan another Nobel Prize
winning invention think of CT like this
with just one x-ray you might be able to
see the density change due to a solid
tumor in a patient but you wouldn't know
how deep it is beneath the surface
however if you take x-rays from multiple
angles you should be able to find the
tumors position and shape a CT scanner
works by sending a fan or cone of x-rays
through a patient to an array of
detectors the x-ray beam is rotated
around the patient and often also moved
down the patient's body with the x-ray
source tracing a spiral trajectory
spiral CT scans produce data that can be
processed into cross-sections detailed
enough to spot anatomical features
tumors blood clots and infections CT
scans can even detect heart disease and
cavities in mummies buried thousands of
years ago so what began as roentgen
Zak's identity now over 100 million
scans each year worldwide to treat
diseases and save lives
Oh